vous avez une minute alors préparez-vous
à être ébloui par le cours la boussole
cette école membre du réseau espérance
banlieu est une pépite en matière
d'éducation dès votre arrivée le
directeur vous accueille par une poignée
de main un regard droit dans les yeux et
la journée commence sur une note
positive chaque matin les élèves se
rassemblent dans la cour pour une
cérémonie unique les élèves méritants
sont appelés et félicités pour leur note
ou pour leur comportement exemplaire et
pour couronner le tout tout le monde
chante la
Marseillaise en ici c'est la méthode
Singapore qui est reine surtout pour
l'enseignement des mathématiques alors
comment font-ils plutôt que de plonger
la tête dans les chiffres on commence
par du concret des objets des images
tout est fait pour rendre les concepts
plus tangibles ils ont toute une armoire
remplie de matériel de bouliers de cube
pour rendre les concepts mathématiques
les plus intuitifs possibles alors si
vous cherchez une école qui sort de
l'ordinaire le cours la boussole et
peut-être l'endroit qu'il vous
faut